[Music]
brought to you by the every dooll app
start budgeting for free today this show
has
um become inordinately successful with
30 million of you so or so out there in
a given month um on YouTube's you know
podcast on uh the various platforms that
680 radio stations that carry us because
we understand that personal finance is
not
math the problem with my
money is the guy I shave
with the mathematics of becoming wealthy
are somewhere you learn them somewhere
around the sixth
grade this is not an intellect problem
this is a behavior problem if I can get
the in my
mirror to behave he can be skinny
and Rich but he's got
issues and he engages in stupid people
tricks to the extent that I have
dysfunction in my
relationships I'm going to struggle to
build wealth to the extent that I have
dysfunction in my behaviors like a lack
of work ethic a lack of
Integrity uh other character issues I'm
going to struggle to build
wealth um to the and so there's a tie in
between your emotional
well-being your relational
Acumen uh that is more predictive of
your ability to become wealthy than your
income in other words you it doesn't
matter what you make if you're addicted
to to cocaine you're going to lose
everything 100% of addicts as an example
of this discussion end up broke
eventually
100% eventually some in 10 months some
in 10 years and they lose everything
that's a misbehavior that caused that
it's not a math problem that caused that
it wasn't they didn't understand how
mutual funds work it wasn't that they
didn't earn an income a lot of cocaine
addicts earn a great
income um and they hide their addiction
but if if you don't know how to interact
with the opposite sex and you
continually choose poorly in your mate
you are going
to make it almost impossible to create a
sustainable Financial life and I isn't
that weird yeah and I'm just haunted by
like that last call haunts me
because when you say it like you you
won't accept this from your for your own
child everyone goes no I would never
accept that but you just become blind to
it and you just keep doing it you just
keep doing it and you keep doing it and
you wonder you keep going back to the
the the money the money issue why are we
broke why are we broke why are we broke
you gota you got to let this Predator
who is praying on you in your time uh
you got to let him go I ain't doing that
all right well there's not there's not
like a crypto secret we can tell you to
help you make money there's not like a
budgeting hack we can give you um you
and him have to go work It's just tough
man if if you're not connected with your
spouse you can have trouble can be a
relational thing I mean it it's um you
know one of the jokes that we had in the
early days of the show was you know if
you marry a woman that that likes
spending you better enjoy working right
you know and so uh but it's also the
opposite way ABS obviously um if you
marry a man that likes spending you
better enjoy working uh and so cuz you
can't but you can't can out earn it and
you can't keep up and the correlation
among millionaires between spouses that
work together and that both shoulder the
load together it's almost 100% of them
yeah the very few people build wealth
dragging a deadbeat along are dragging
someone who's misbehaving in some area
of their life along someone who won't
work someone who uh can't tell the truth
someone that won't file their taxes uh
someone that uh you know lies all the
time uh you know you you just these
dysfunctional people that are in all of
our Lives to the extent that they are uh
that we're wrapped up with them pretty
much ensures that we're going to create
a a situation where we can't build a
sustainable financial situation one of
the reasons I've been able to build
wealth is my wife is a freaking Rock
right she's a rock I mean the number the
amount of drama in 43 years I've had at
home when I got home at night with
little kids at home was precisely zero
yeah the only drama my I bring it
occasionally there was drama before I
got there right but it's not like wait
till your daddy gets home no fear the
wrath of Sharon instead you know I mean
it's like I there is not a you know I
was not having to carry three or four
things around while I was at work I was
carrying work around and it's why we
were able to make such progress yeah
it's it's fun they they say the one of
the the greatest um determinants for joy
happiness in your life is marry well
it's the most important decision you
make because marrying poorly um it's
disproportionate how bad your life is
and marrying well it's disproportion how
wonderful it makes your life but our
friend Dr Henry cloud with the book
boundaries whether it is your marriage
partner or not just the other people in
your life your business partner your
your Budd suck the marrow out of your
your bones right because you won't put
up a boundary right or for some reason
don't know to put up a boundary you
weren't raised in such a way well I was
raised you always take care of daddy
well uh did you notice that your daddy
is a problem right or um well that's
just so and so like stop that's just the
way he is I I would love a great
exercise for folks is to write down the
the top five to 10 to 15 people in your
life they can be co-workers they can be
family members they can be friends
if you're lucky you got 10 in this
current world we live in if you got if
you're you're exceptionally lucky if you
got 15 write them down and just draw a
line across the paper and say vampire or
contributor is this a person that when I
get done being around them I'm just like
GH or I get done being around them and I
can't wait to go hang out again they are
somebody that that brings me up and I I
challenge you in 20124 to find
Opportunities to be around vampire
people less yeah and be around those who
pour into you who are excited who
challenge you more and that doesn't mean
you get along all the time like some of
the people who contribute most of my
life man we are button heads all the
time and I love them and I I believe the
very similar things with some of the
most vampiric people I just made that
word up that just you get done it's like
golly dude I feel like I was just
slogging through quicksand I mean when
you come out of a meeting or you come
out of a social gathering with someone
and you feel like you need to take a
shower I don't want to repeat this right
I'm done right and my wife's like well
we need to be nice no I don't need to be
nice we need to be nice to us so that we
not going to be nice I can be nice from
a further distance I'll wave from over
there you know but this this close
physical proximity with slime is a
problem yeah you know and it's um you
know and it's okay I'm not it's not that
I'm a snob no I like you but I'm not
going to hang out with you yeah I'm it's
it's uh I can be nice to you I can help
you love you I'm I can encourage you but
I'm not going you're not going to be
part of my crew that's right yeah
because you become who you hang around
with and if you find out that you're
married to somebody who is more of a
vampire than a contributor this is the
Year let this be the year that you put
that on the table and say let's build
something new let's let's build
something new yeah I'm taking your sharp
teeth yeah well or like the first caller
of of this hour that I'm going to be
clear for the first time because I find
myself I don't like you I don't want to
be around you the things you do annoy me
and I I I kind of H and haul and hint
I've never just been honest with you
just never told you let's put all that
on the table this year decide to uh heal
this thing moving forward because at
some point um there are people in the
margins that are struggling that's not
who I'm talking to I'm talking to most
of us most of us at some point choose
the relationships we have and we choose
the the dance that we choose to do in
those things and at somebody at some
point somebody's got to pull pull the
pull the rip cord and say this this
one's over this one's over we're going
to build something new and the reason
for the sidebar right now is this this
is the time of year to look at this and
say okay I want you to leave from this
little little rant that we've done for
the last five minutes I want you to
leave with this idea who you hang around
with and who you are going to create
relationship with is 100x more important
towards whether you're able to build
wealth than whether you understand how a
mutual fund works or what your income is
they're going to screw up your
life if you let them create your free
every dollar budget today the simplest
way to budget for your life